thanks to Skillshare for keeping legal
eagle in the air learn to think like a
lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description the
president has declared a national
emergency and is using that as
justification to build his wall can he
do that in ancient Rome the dictator was
a temporary position given to the head
of state in times of emergency so giving
emergency power to the president is not
a new idea but there's nothing like that
in the Constitution the Constitution
makes no provision for a national
emergency and does not recognize
anything like emergency powers but some
argue that the president has been
delegated those powers by Congress so
today we're gonna talk about president
Trump's emergency declaration number one
I want to talk about what emergency
powers the president does actually have
number two I want to talk about whether
there is in fact an emergency that
allows the president to invoke those
powers number three I want to talk about
what powers Congress has and which it
has bestowed on the president and number
four I want to talk about the possible
outcomes that may come as a result of
this national emergency declaration and
what that means for future presidents in
other words are we going to see a lot of
new declarations of national emergencies
over things like the environment gun
control or healthcare so let's talk
about the first question what emergency
powers does the president have and can
the president act outside of those
enumerated powers well with few
exceptions the president can only act
with congressional authorization the
president has broad executive and
enforcement authority to use his or her
discretion to determine how to enforce
the law or how to otherwise manage the
resources of the executive branch but
the president has virtually no authority
to pass laws or appropriate funds
without Congress and in fact in the
famous case of Youngstown Sheet & Tube
company versus Sawyer the Supreme Court
ruled that President Harry Truman's
attempt to nationalize US steel mills
during a strike in the Korean War was in
fact unconstitutional so as one Congress
person has said if Harry Truman couldn't
nationalize the steel industry during
wartime this president doesn't have the
power to declare an emergency and build
a multi-billion dollar wall on
border now one of the first fundamental
issues that is implicated by this
emergency declaration is the
appropriations issue according to
article 1 of the Constitution only
Congress can appropriate federal funds
article 1 section 1 of the US
Constitution states that all legislative
powers herein are granted and shall be
vested in the Congress article 1 section
8 states that Congress has the exclusive
spending power to quote provide for the
general welfare of the United States
lawsuits have already been filed stating
that President Trump has violated the
United States Constitution's separation
of powers doctrine by taking executive
action to fund a border wall without
Congress actually appropriating the
correct funding those lawsuits have
argued that the 2019 Appropriations Act
is an explicit denial of the president's
requested funds for the border wall
those lawsuits also argue that the
president has violated the separation of
powers doctrine by unilaterally
diverting funds that Congress has
already appropriated for other things
that are not related to the border wall
and article 1 section 9 of the
Constitution states that no money shall
be drawn from the Treasury but in
consequence of appropriations made by
law the lawsuits argue that Congress
heard the president's requests and
explicitly rejected the request to
appropriate funds to build any kind of
border wall so the recent attorneys
general lawsuit argues that President
Trump violated the Appropriations Clause
the Constitution by funding construction
for a border wall with funds that were
not appropriated for that purpose but
here the Trump administration will
counter that Congress has in fact passed
a law that gives him authority to do
this a number of laws do in fact
authorize the President to take certain
actions by declaring a national
emergency the primary law that the
president seems to be operating under is
the national emergencies act of 1976 as
amended in 1985 which governs the
president's declaration of a national
emergency now under the NEA the
president must specifically state the
law under which he proposes to act and
he still has to comply with a provision
of that law this is incredibly important
because the re-designated funds must
still comply with the original law under
which the funds were appropriated the
first preliminary issue is can the
president even invoke the NEA in these
circumstances the question is is there
an emergency and it also depends on what
the definition of an emergency is the
term emergency is not defined in the
national emergencies act and this fact
cuts in a couple of different directions
on the one hand some argue that this
gives the president carte blanche to
declare anything an emergency because
the NEA doesn't specify what constitutes
an emergency but I think that misses the
point one of the jobs of the courts from
time immemorial is to provide
definitions where a particular statute
is silent or ambiguous in the case of
federal laws courts often look to the
intent of Congress to impute a
definition to an otherwise undefined
term and let's be clear there is no
emergency as most people understand that
word Merriam Webster's defines emergency
has a unforeseen combination of
circumstances or the resulting state
that calls for immediate action
president Trump has said himself that
this was not strictly necessary he could
have gone through regular channels but
he wanted to do it faster I want to do
it faster I could do the wall over a
longer period of time I didn't need to
do this but I'd rather do it much faster
and in the present day illegal
immigration is at near historic lows the
President may not be satisfied with
those numbers but as most people
understand the lay definition of
emergency it doesn't seem like there's
any argument that it fits it seems very
likely that this is not the kind of
situation that Congress had in mind when
passing the 1976 national emergencies
act in fact that particular law was an
attempt to curtail presidential power
that had been exercised by the Nixon
administration so it is possible that
the court will defer to whatever the
president declares as a national
emergency I don't think the courts that
look at this will do so in part because
of the political ramifications that
might allow future presidents to declare
whatever they want as an emergency but
that being said
it isn't uncommon for courts to have to
weigh in on the definitions of terms in
various laws and if the court uses a
layer of emergency then it's likely that
this particular situation would not
qualify and that may end the analysis of
this particular legal question right
there but let's assume for the sake of
argument that this does qualify as a
national emergency or the court takes a
deferential view that says basically
anything can be a national emergency
well now that means that we have to look
at the second part what laws are invoked
in order to re-appropriate the funds
because as I mentioned before the
president still has to comply with the
underlying laws that pass the funds in
the first place one of the laws that the
president is relying on to receive the
lion's share of the billions of dollars
he's asking for border wall construction
deals with military construction under
this military construction law 33 USC
2293 the president may turn eighth or
defer military construction that he has
deemed non-essential to the National
Defense and may apply those resources
for a project to construct another
project which he considers essential but
the reappropriation funds under this
particular law must still constitute
military construction and given the fact
that we are not at war with Mexico it
makes it a hard sell to claim that a
border wall is a military construction
project in addition this particular
construction project does not require
the Armed Forces to build and in fact
there is an argument to be made that the
military cannot be used to build this
particular project under the Posse
Comitatus rule Posse Comitatus is a
doctrine that is enshrined in statutory
law in the United States it says you
cannot use the military for domestic
projects especially not enforcement you
might recall that when President Trump
sent troops to the border to fight
against an alleged caravan of potential
immigrants and refugees they weren't
actually sent to the border to fight but
really to only provide backup services
to the department of homeland security
that was largely because of the doctrine
of Posse Comitatus which says that you
cannot use Armed Forces domestically so
even if the press
and is able to get over the hurdle of
declaring a national emergency he's
still going to have a number of hurdles
with respect to the underlying law from
which he is taking the appropriated
funds now on the other hand the
government will probably argue that the
courts should give broad deference to
the president's determination that there
is a national emergency and also broad
deference as to what constitutes
military construction as the
commander-in-chief of the Armed Forces
we don't often want to be able to
second-guess the commander-in-chief's
ability to declare what is essential to
the national defense and what isn't so
if this case gets to the Supreme Court
and isn't bounced on some technicality
it's completely unclear which way the
Supreme Court might go on this there are
long strings of cases that are
deferential to the president and the
president's authority to act where the
Constitution allows it so this is
certainly not a slam dunk for either
side and this is also one of those areas
where the traditional cleavages of
liberal versus conservative justices on
the Supreme Court don't always make
sense sometimes the conservative
justices vote to curtail executive power
and sometimes the more liberal members
of the Supreme Court take the view that
the executive power should be very
expansive so when it comes to who might
view this as an overreach and who might
view this as a perfectly reasonable
thing for a president to do all bets are
off
I should note however that litigation
over this emergency declaration is going
to have issues with standing and
ripeness this is always a perennial
issue when you have these kinds of acts
and political questions in order to file
a lawsuit you have to have what's called
standing which means that you have to be
personally aggrieved in order to file
suit and in terms of standing individual
members of Congress do not have standing
but sometimes Congress as a body does
sometimes affected states have standing
sometimes they don't there's also the
issue of ripeness since only the
declaration has been made and no action
has actually been taken it's not clear
that this case is actually ripe for
adjudication but the recent litigation
in California which deals with dozens of
states dozens of
it's attorneys general and several
farmers who are likely to be affected by
this emergency declaration looks to
solve some of those standing and
ripeness issues but no matter what this
will have huge implications for future
presidential actions those on both sides
of the aisle are right to worry about
the president in this particular setting
when the Senate passed the national
emergencies act it's stated in the notes
of passage that the NEA was designed to
ensure that the president's
extraordinary emergency powers would be
utilized only when emergencies actually
exist under the national emergencies act
Congress has 18 days to adopt joint
resolution to terminate the declaration
but that joint resolution is subject to
a presidential veto and recent Supreme
Court Authority has stated that a
presidential veto can only be overturned
by a two-thirds vote in both houses and
this is incredibly unlikely so that
means that if the court upholds the
Trump administration's declaration of
emergency here the likely outcome is
that the next president and potentially
the president after that is likely to be
able to declare almost anything a
national emergency in that case as well
and at least in my opinion that seems
like exactly what the framers of the
Constitution trying to avoid when they
gave the exclusive right to pass laws
and the exclusive right to make
appropriations only to Congress
President Trump made a major mistake by
saying that he didn't need to issue the
declaration of emergency and could have
used the regular legislative process he
really could have benefited from Soledad
O'Brien's Skillshare class powerful
story telling today if he had taken the
class on crafting a great story and
message his legal defense would be in
much better shape he also could have
benefited from Simon to next class on
how to share ideas that inspire action
because so far the only action that
President Trump has inspired is a bunch
of lawsuits Skillshare is an online
learning community that has over 20,000
classes on everything like leadership
technology and business the first 500
legal eagles will get two free months of
Skillshare when you click on the link
below the free premium membership gives
you unlimited access to must know topics
so you can improve your skills and learn
new things and prove yourself now and
avoid your own personal emerge
so click on the link get two free months
and start learning to think like a
lawyer today so do you agree leave your
objections in the comments check out my
other real law reviews here for more
legal analysis and until next time I'll
see you in court